When I saw the punishment, it was a shockingly large recovery.Is it
nostalgic?
I'll show
you, what kind of coin is this
? It's not an elevator
, it's a world where many people aim to go up, so elevators like this are also a business.The
higher you go, the more it costs.  I thought it was more like a dungeon,
but of
course that's what it looks like.
My name is Kiho, but I'm sorry Meow meow I
bought fried bread at that store over there The fried bread here
is famous for being exquisite It's a tourist spot
It smells good Give me a
little  Music] There's a
lot to see, but let's aim for the 11th time.There's still a long
way to go, so 505 per person for wildlife protection costs is fine
.
It seems like it's
strange
Bach
ah ah ah ah ah ah
[music]
ah ah
no there is no temple
there are many strong demons among the tourists so they seem to have stopped rebelling,
rather they have a habit of bowing their heads and aiming for rice